because I hate when I feel like I'm
trying to be funny so what I says to
myself is don't try to be funny be
boring that's my thing to be like just
beer that's how I try to psych myself
into being genuine leave boring don't
try to be funny
that's all no but Dad because I hate
when I'm trying to be funny and I see
myself being like like coming up that's
so disability in the car we were like
okay try be boring great yeah you know
like before I did hot once I was [ __ ] oh
yeah why cuz I love that show so much
yeah and I love Sean Evans and I love
everything they do and I was just like
be just be [ __ ] boring that was my
mantra yeah just don't drive just be
boring just answers questions you know
and it'll work out yeah it's great right
yeah happy would you finish can I finish
- yeah but here's the thing with that
one is what I do is this is I so I also
don't listen like when I did hot ones I
didn't know anything about it mmm-hmm
really yeah yeah and the what an
assistant at the agency that I'm with
goes I think I can get you on it I like
I don't want to know I don't want to do
it music I think you should do it like
everyone's they gave me the list of
people I got that's all I want to know
about it I'm not gonna look it up why
just that's because if I if I think that
it's like you know like today I got Anna
Faris who's people calling you want to
do Anna Faris I know her I know I'm a
fan alright I think that she's a great
you know and like I watched her movies I
thought that she's great I was in a
movie with her she was in The Dictator
she was you know I had five lines but it
doesn't matter we spend days together
you know I love her but because I have
this thing I elevate her right it's
gonna [ __ ] with ya you need your you're
about power balances I feel like
balancing you're very aware of power
balance yeah like with you
riot I didn't really I knew that you
guys were big but I didn't read you know
you gotta get a different way you know
you're big in the same way you're in the
[ __ ] same way but I told George I go
I didn't want to know your names
until when I've met you go until right
when we walked into the [ __ ] thing
and then walk in by the way that show
was great fan favorite one of one of my
favorite show was I got so many good
response so far yeah yeah
[Laughter]
is that what I do then oh my god
[Music]